and liftoff rocketing towards the  International Space Station a soyuz  rocket carrying new crew member to the  International Space Station blasted off  overnight from Kazakhstan a pioneering  NASA astronaut on board is making  history or her story Peggy Whitson is  now the oldest woman in space in  February she will celebrate for a 57th  birthday aboard the space station  Whitson has already spent 377 days in  orbit during her career she's also the  first woman to serve as commander of the  space station yeah they're going Eddie 7  the oldest woman I call that young don't  you go Peggy no Peggy go baby go Peggy  go that's a great story I love that me  too